in this segment we look into the
probability that the sum of ten
independent identically distributed
random variables takes an abnormally
large value we will get an upper bound
on this quantity which is known as
hurtings inequality this is an upper
bound that applies to a special case
although the method actually generalizes
here is the special case that we will
consider the random variables the x i's
are equally likely to take the values
minus one and plus one with equal
probability and we're interested in the
random variable which is the sum of the
x's what do we know about this random
variable well the expected value of each
one of the x i's is equal to zero
because the distribution is symmetric
and also the distance of X I from the
mean has always magnitude one and for
this reason the variance of the x i's is
equal to one for this reason the random
variable Y has a mean of 0 and a
variance equal to n now what do we know
about the random variable Y by the
central limit theorem Y has an
approximately normal distribution the
distribution is centered at 0 and also
the random variable Y over square root
of n this is a standardized random
variable so it's approximately normal
and so the probability that this number
is larger than or equal to sum a is
approximately 1 minus the cumulative of
the standard normal so Phi here stands
for the standard normal CDF
what does this tell us it tells us that
if we take somewhere here the number
square root of n times a then this
probability down here in the tail is
approximately constant no matter what n
is and this in particular tells us that
values of the order of square root n are
fairly likely to occur however what were
interested in here is not being larger
than square root n times a we're
interested in being larger than n times
a so we're talking about what happens
further down in the tail of the
distribution so if we take here n times
a we're looking at this probability down
here and we want to ask how small is
that probability while we have
chebyshev's inequality and chebyshev's
inequality tells us that the probability
of Y being larger than a certain number
is less than or equal to the variance of
Y divided by the square of that number
and in this case since the variance is n
this is 1 over N squared so chebyshev's
inequality tells us that this
probability goes to 0 and it goes to 0
at least as fast as 1 over n goes to 0
however it turns out that this is
extremely conservative halflings
inequality which we're going to
establish tells us something much
stronger it tells us that this tail
probability down here
Falls exponentially with n so this is
what we want to show and let us get
started to see how the derivation goes
the derivation relies on a beautiful
trick instead of looking at this event
here we're going to look at the
following equivalent event let us fix
number s we're going to leave the choice
of s free for now it is only that we're
going to assume that s is a positive
number
and throughout we're also assuming that
a is also a positive number now we look
at this quantity and the event that this
quantity is larger than or equal to e to
the S and times a now this sum is larger
than or equal to n a if and only if this
quantity is larger than or equal to e to
the S and a this is because a and s are
both positive so the direction of the
inequalities does not get reversed and
also because the exponential function is
monotonic so this event is the same as
that event so we will try to say
something about the probability of this
event how are we going to do it we will
use the markov inequality where z is the
random variable that appears here so by
Markov inequality this probability is
less than or equal to the expected value
of the random variable that we are
dealing with divided by this value
now the exponential of Assam we can
factor it as a product of Exponential's
and then we use the assumption that the
axes are independent since the axes are
independent e to the S x1 is independent
from e to the S x2 and so on
and so we have the expected value of a
product of independent random variables
and so this is equal to the product of
the expectations so we're going to
multiply the expected value of e to the
SX 1 with the expected value of e to the
S x2 and so on but because all the x i's
are identically distributed the terms
that we get are all the same so we get
this term to the nth power divided again
by e to the SN a or we can write this in
more suggestive form as follows it's the
expected value of e to the s x1 divided
by e to the si
all that to the nth power so think of
that as being some number Rho to the nth
power
when is this bound going to be
interesting it's going to be interesting
if Rho is less than 1 because in that
case this bound Falls exponentially with
N and so this probability in particular
will fall exponentially with n the key
here is that we have freedom to choose s
for any value of s we obtain an upper
bound we're going to choose s so that we
get the most informative or a most
powerful upper bound so let us continue
to see what we can do first let us write
down what this expected value is since
x1 takes values minus 1 or plus 1 with
equal probability this expectation is
the following with probability 1/2
x1 takes the value of 1 and so this
random variable is e to the S and with
probability 1/2 it takes the value minus
1 in which case this random variable is
e to the minus s so this is the
expectation the numerator and we write
again the term in the denominator and we
have all this to the power n if we can
choose s so that this quantity is less
than 1 we will have achieved our
objective can we do that let's see let's
look at the numerator as a function of s
when s is equal to 0 we have 1 plus 1
divided by 1/2 that gives us 1 and then
as s moves away from 0 this function
will have this kind of shape and it is
symmetric around 0 because we have an S
and the minus s here in particular the
derivative of this function is 0 at 0
let's look at the denominator term the
denominator term is an exponential a is
a positive number so it's an exponential
that has a shape of this kind the
important thing to notice is that this
exponential has a positive derivative at
0 what does it tell us that at least in
the vicinity of 0 this term the
denominator is going to be larger than
the numerator term and that implies that
in the vicinity of 0 this fraction is
going to be less than 1 and we will have
achieved our goal of an exponentially
decaying bound so the conclusion is that
for small s
we have that raw is less than one now we
would like to get an explicit value for
raw and we will do that by fixing a
specific value for s it turns out that
if we set s to be equal to a then the
bound that we get is going to be that
this probability here is less than or
equal to e to the minus n a squared over
two and this is the hafting bound at
this point you may just pause or if
you're curious you can continue with
this video to see the algebraic
manipulations involved in order to show
that this expression is less than or
equal to that expression but before
going there I would like to make a
general comment even if the axis had a
different distribution but with zero
mean the derivation up to this point
would go through here you would have
somewhat different expression for the
expected value of e to the SX 1 however
it turns out that the expression that
you get here will always have this
property that it has a 0 derivative this
is a consequence of the assumption that
we assumed zero mean and because of that
we will still have a picture of this
kind and so this fraction will always be
less than 1 when we choose s to be
suitably small and so this is going to
give us a result for more general
distributions and that more general
result is known as the Chernoff bound
however we will not develop in this
video the churn of bounds in its greater
generality we will just stay with
rafting sin equality that gives us the
basic idea and what we will do next will
be to derive this inequality
so I'm carrying over what we figured out
in the previous slide and this is the
quantity here that we wish to bound we
will look at the numerator term and
we're going to use a Taylor series for
the exponential function remember the
Taylor series for the exponential
function takes this form and using that
we have 1/2 e to the s plus e to the
minus s is equal to the following we
first write the Taylor series for e to
the s I'm just copying from here so 1
plus s plus s squared over 2 factorial
plus s cube over 3 factorial and we
continue similarly and then for the term
e to the minus s we have a similar
expansion except that we put a minus s
in the place of s now minus s squared is
the same as s squared with a plus sign
but for s cube when we have minus s this
becomes minus s cube and so on and so we
see that in this expansion here we will
alternate between positive and negative
signs this means that all the odd power
terms will cancel each other but the
even power terms will survive so what we
obtain is the sum of all those terms but
we only have the even power terms so we
have powers of the form two I these are
the even integers and in the
denominators we will always have the
factorial of whatever exponent we have
at the top
now let us get a bounce on this term in
the denominator
- I factorial is 1 times 2 times 3 all
the way up to I and then we continue I
plus 1 I plus 2 all the way up to 2i and
what we have is first I factorial but
then each one of these terms is larger
than or equal to 2 and we have I such
terms and this gives us this inequality
so we're going to use this substitution
here because this term is in the
denominator the direction of the
inequality is going to be reversed and
we obtain this
now we can rewrite this by taking this
term two to the AI and combining it with
the other term in the numerator and what
we have is s squared divided by two all
of that to the ice power
now does this expression look familiar
it is of exactly the same form as this
expansion but instead of s we now have a
squared over two therefore this is equal
to e to the s squared over two so we
managed to bound this term using now
this bound we go back to this inequality
and we have that this is less than or
equal to in the numerator we have e to
the S squared over two in the
denominator we have e to the s a and all
that is raised to the nth power or
another way to write this is e to the S
squared over two minus s a and all that
to the nth power and now if I choose s
equal to a what I obtain here is going
to be e to the a squared over two minus
a squared that leaves me with e to the
minus a squared over two and then I take
this factor of n as well and the final
conclusion is that this quantity becomes
equal to this term and so we have
completed the derivation that this
expression is less than or equal to this
quantity when we choose as equal to a
and this is half things in equality